[Música]
boa noite
eu sou maria pérola pernambucana cantora
compositora psicóloga e mulher negra
periférica também é então por que
emocionada
uau que história né eu vou começar
cantando a música em homenagem a todas
as mulheres que passaram aqui neste
palco mulheres fortes que tomaram o seu
lugar de fala e deixar uma mensagem que
eu tenho certeza é querido que é um
presente para todos e vou pedir pra
colocar uma imagem aqui atrás como
referência
de uma mulher que lutou contra a milícia
para defender seus filhos também né
filhos da periferia e vou fazer um vou
cantar uma versão de duas queridas à
silvia do flyer e a doralice uma carioca
o trabalho ana fizeram uma versão de
mulheres
eu vou cantar para vocês e oferecer a
todas as mulheres que passaram aqui com
suas histórias incríveis
é isso aí vamos nós somos mulheres de
todas as cores de várias idades de
muitos amores lembrou de andar a mulher
que eu sei de algumas horas mulher
fora da lei
lembro mary helly valente e guerreira de
xica da silva toda a mulher brasileira
crescendo oprimida pelo patriarcado meu
corpo minhas regras agora o docu
mulheres cabeças em luta que lembrar da
jen está confuso não que plantem nada
são elas por anja escuta-se samba que eu
vou te contar
eu não sei por que eu tenho que ser tua
felicidade
não sou sua projeção você é que se baixe
meu temor assim caro junto de mim
sou mulher sou dona do meu corpo e da
minha vontade foi o que descobri prazer
e liberdade psol tudo que um dia eu
sonhei pra mim
nós somos mulheres de todas as cores de
várias idades de muitos amores lembro de
dândara mulher que eu sei que deus
a soares mulher fora da lei
lembro de anastácia valente e guerreira
e xica da silva toda mulher brasileira
crescendo a primeira pelo patriarcado
meu corpo minhas regras agora mudou o
quadro mulheres cabeças e muita
calibrada ninguém está confusa não te
pegam tem nada suas por elas
escuta-se samba que eu vou te cantar eu
não sei por que tenho que ser tua
felicidade não só sua projeção você aqui
se baste
meu pai é amor assim caro um anjo de mim
sou mulher sou dona do meu corpo e da
minha vontade
fui eu que descobri prazer e liberdade
sou tudo que um dia eu sonhei pra mim
sou mulher sou dona do meu corpo e da
minha vontade
fui eu que descobri prazer e liberdade
solto do que um dia eu sonhei pra mim
obrigada obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
eu acho que que essa é a mensagem né
as mulheres hoje estão tomando os seus
lugares por direito na literatura no
cinema na música na produção
empreendendo né
isso é lindo o mundo é nossa vamos
dominar o mundo inteiro e vovô cantar a
música agora o bulls ainda há aqui gente
tá aqui né
buza tem um projeto muito massa que é o
sarau suburbano e eu conheci tem um
tempinho e a biblioteca estava passando
por um perrengue sair a gente fez um
sarau né coletivo para arrecadar uma
grana e saiu de lá naquele dia
depois daquela troca maravilhosa e ver
tantos poetas e poetisas músicos
periféricos levando sua arte marginal
eu fiz uma música que se chama música
popular periférica eu vou contar pra
vocês ofereceu querido busic faz um
trabalho incrível também e vocês vão me
ajudar cantar uma o refrão é assim
périssé ea dell sinal perry fere a
dancinha vocês é o pé
mais um vez é perry beijo perry fere a
[Música]
acorda cedo desce apela olha o sol do
dia
hoje eu cansar a acorda cedo desce a
viela da bundinha olha o sol rabis
converso reserva
hoje eu reclamo no ceará é a deu sinal
você espere periféria da pele feriada
faz uma música diferente ladrão pra
amenizar o calor da dor que é produzir
seu próprio som com o seu sonho matinal
você prefere
[Música]
perry fé ea deus não
perry feria bem do lado de cada pontim a
gente também quer crescer comunidade a
coletivo pra entender
surpreenda quebrada
surpreenda quebrada não diz médici o seu
lugar de fala
surpreenda quebrada surpreenda quebrada
não desperdice o seu lugar de erick
vereador deu periferia a dançarina
périssé e adelsin não mais um
perry a deu sinal está perry fere a deu
senão ele feria deus périssé até deus e
fere a dell sinan
obrigada gente muito obrigada
é a pedidos do organizador também do
evento
eu vou fazer uma versão aqui de um
grande artista da zona sul grajaú
e quem souber canta comigo vamos lá
[Música]
aliás um salve para quem for do grajaú e
tive aqui
[Música]
essa música fala da realidade é que a
gente precisa mudar não existe amor
esse é um abrindo méxico onde os
grafites gritam não dá pra descrever uma
linda frase de um postal tão doce
cuidado com dos são paulo é um buquê é
porque são flores mortas no lindo anjo
arranjo lindo fei pra você
não existe amor e se tem
[Música]
os bares estão cheias de almas tão vazia
e à ganância vibra vai da de sita
devolva minha vida emborra foga da em
seu próprio marcel aki ninguém vai trair
os han
é
van
[Música]
não precisa morrer pra ver deus não
precisa sofrer para saber o que é melhor
pra você não precisa morrer pra ver deus
encontrou duas nuvens em cádiz com
brincadeiras que não me deu um cara de
vida não existe amor encontro duas
nuvens em cada 10 com brincadeiras que
não me deu um gole e vida vida não
existe amor psp
um fã
[Música]
não existe amor não existe amor
não existe amor existe
obrigada obrigada
é eu estou muito feliz de estar aqui é
uma troca uma experiência incrível para
mim pra vocês também tenho certeza e eu
vou me despedir com a canção de minha
autoria
acho que todos que passaram por aqui
contando um pouco das suas histórias das
suas vivências
eles deixaram benito do a questão da
solitude se empregar de se conhecer e
ter o seu tempo de respeitar o seu
processo e essa música fala um pouco
disso fala de ter suas vivências
estudadas né conhecidas aceitas e deixar
o passado correr focar no futuro o nosso
passado é o que fortifica a nossa visão
de presente e futuro isso que é
importante
ela se chama solitude vou contar pra
vocês e me despedir
espero que vocês tenham gostado
[Música]
olhos embaçados lhes no retrovisor ou
ice ao ganda boca
[Música]
o tempo foi tão generoso do lado de cá
eu sei que ele também foi terno por aí
foi bom até demais despe a uma efeito em
faz parte o olhando para trás de nós diz
pra onde não voltar é
[Música]
a solitude a double a flor forma
imediata interrupção do a
choveu no solo ser o do lado de cá que
os ventos levem chuva por aí
foi bom até demais de espiar alma efeito
em faz parte o olhando para trás nos dê
pra onde não voltar
é é
é
a van
[Música]
partilhei olhando para trás nós desde
praga onde não voltar
[Música]
ah
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]